good morning Millennials how relatable
am i with the way I'm sitting and my
Busy Philipps tanea to put both feet up
take your shoes off and ask bad
questions or ask that question no like
what do you inspired what I wanted to
say one more thing one I wanted to tear
apart Busy Philipps one more time
because there was something so pertinent
that it couldn't wait till next week no
and it couldn't wait till later in the
show Kim on the episode before talks
about how she hates champagne and
everybody hates champagne and it's so
gross she's sitting on busy two tonight
with the glass of champagne like busy
has her margarita and she gave Kim a
glass of champagne and Kim's talking
about how like she doesn't drink no but
like she specifically said in the
episode like champagne is that she
doesn't drink it anymore she used to
only drink champagne and then she said
it's gross and then that's what busy
gave her I mean I don't know how to
nights in a row I ended up watching busy
tonight I also watched you last night
with Wilmer Valderrama and he was like
on his phone in the beginning and it's
like everyone who goes on her show was
bored and sits there on their phone back
at least that's an option you know yeah
no it's just like yeah for sure I just
wanted to point out that one glaring
hypocrisy that just shows that she
didn't watch episode and wasn't in tune
with what's necessary I really look like
I'm going to a funeral today like cousin
wearing like a blouse and like a dark
one see look like you're going to the
death of a rockstar I mean Elvis
oh yeah that's who's on my shirt it's
cute he's in the building you guys just
like James Dean who didn't die until
April Elvis has left the building it's
not in the bill but he's in the building
because I'm wearing a shirt okay I know
that's a say okay he's in the building
today
phrase was like he's in the building did
you know today he is yes he is just like
James Dean who didn't die in till April
no no there's a conspiracy theory that
Elvis didn't die like that he's still
rebuilding these stupid-ass conspiracy
theory is that I pretty much you know
give life to actually they've got to
stop because they're getting more
increasingly more out of control yeah
they're it's Elvis
James Dean who hung Tupac yeah Shakur I
don't know you guys it's just exciting
regardless of what happens and that
would mean that James Dean was alive to
hear that song about him you got that
James Dean day dream look in your eye
and I got that red lip class sick sing
that you I can't let me go crashing down
we come back every time because we never
go out of style we never go out of style
you got that long hair slicked back
white t-shirt and I got that good girl
thing and it's a little Scott and
romaine go crashing down we come back
every time cause we never go out of
style we never go out just take me out
just take me oh yeah take me out
[Music]
cool earrings bro thanks I knew you were
gonna say something cuz you did give
them some and it's still them like them
to you happily well I don't think you
brought them back because they are
uncovered with my infectious disease
that I think I've strep
well ears and earrings are actually
services like I say you think you have
strep you know I know I have strep like
you know when you know sure when you
can't swallow in your back hurt it's
like that strap Oh bye I woke up in the
middle of the night screaming like being
an animal oh god what about Theo he's
suffering from kennel cough and I think
that we are like getting each other sick
is that possible yeah and me and Jackie
just have like such a big night tonight
and I just I don't have it in me I'm
like I'm really so sick no but like it's
a big night but all you have to do is
show up you know it's not like you busy
like tear up the dance floor Jack and I
are hitting the Daily Mail holiday party
and I don't really know what I'm wearing
which is just like some annoying I'm
wearing something so festive per usual
so call it like I literally can't not
wear a bow in the month of December it's
impossible impossible for a plain yellow
pumpkin to become a golden carriage
yellow pumpkin it's orange is are those
the words I don't know I was gonna start
sayin Kimmy [ __ ]
Oh totally
well you guys buy that I just brief
update life update Jackie and I have
made some really promising up
progression strides you know English is
so hard for me sometimes some promising
strides in our quest to join back our
old country club we are me I got the
application I can I can do the price I
think because me and beg got a young
family so it's lower and I think I'm
gonna do it and you're gonna do it a
hundred percent there's no thing it's
just like where do I sign up when can i
when can I start coming like it's there
a new members entry date right now was
so funny when she like the lady sent me
the seven she was also like there's a
minimum you know food and I don't
[ __ ] worry
don't lock that out in two lunches oh my
god I'm so excited but like I was
looking at them but I'm saying they were
touting their new chef and it's like I'm
so optimistic and I'm ready to try it
but like I'm little change too much you
know I mean I have three things that I
have to go when I go back to the Country
Club there's three things after you
actually there's like four the first is
on the kids many of the mini pizza that
have like the thick ass crossed
also the adults thin crust pizza that
was literally as thin as a piece of
paper
- the only salad I ever really liked
before I was like 16 was a Caesar salad
from there like it was so delicious so
good the cheese was just like long parm
strings and the balsamic there is
award-winning also you know I fell in
love with the breast of grilled chicken
at sea we captured up jacking always
make money where kids cloudy used to
always order a breast of girl chicken
but we were kids and she was saying
breath and also I ordered it weird I
couldn't you'd be like I can have girl
checking I had to be like may have a
breast of grilled chicken please yeah
and a lightly toasted bun
it was so faint really Brad Jake is
still though that for sure but we're not
kids anymore so it's like less
inappropriate for you to say breasts I
guess you talk about your breasts all
the time about is speaking up I finally
got my cha-cha-cha from shark tank okay
me too
and either I ordered the wrong size or
it doesn't work I think well I didn't
try it I put it on over my shirt and was
like what size did you get I think I got
a small because even though I have large
loves drugs yeah um like I have a small
neck to back ratio yeah you know they're
like so I thought I would make up for it
I didn't I I haven't fully tried it on
yet so I can't say I was having such a
hard time with my boob like kept
flopping out and like pulling on my back
right your back hurt
yeah like literally I tried to get it in
and like my boob would flop out and like
just the weight of my boob like gravity
that pulled on my neck straight he was
like it was that well for me it was just
really highly and again I did it over
many shirts it doesn't count it was
really highlighting how different size
my two boobs are cuz I was really I
think the small fit one boob not the
other boob interesting there was a girl
on my bunk when we were in camp who had
like different size boobs but like an A
and a D okay and for me it's it's not
that serious but it's there no but but
it's there forever there is a difference
yeah even been as one boob the other he
does he always talked about like his one
boob with like a little puppy I'm crying
what were we talking about
I've no [ __ ] idea my flu Ellie now
see Wayne oh the food oh yes I changed
our perception on food also the grilled
cheese that they made yes but the cousin
with the closed end also I remember when
I was really uneasy eat so healthy when
we were young and all I wanted to do is
try a choco taco and my dream was to
lose a lot of weight so I could have a
choco taco if you never had a choco taco
like not really because I never
accomplish my dream can I tell you
something they're not that good they're
like soggy no but I just have to
accomplish a dream okay you know I'm
just like really looking forward and I
just want to know like once the
applications in like when can I have
lunch you know I think you can have
lunch before the applications and like
you can I think I need to get mcli you
could scam a lunch
just like pretending like you're trying
to join even though I know you're really
joining oh yeah I guess you need to get
a card I think okay so here's my
thinking the thing with the car is like
it's not even the monthly lease fee that
like gets me it's the parking cuz like I
don't need a denies this card can get a
car for like three hours a month but
actually want GPS like maybe 400 but
then it's like what do I do with the
[ __ ] car once I'm home
you have to just splurge for a parking
garage because it'll just make your life
so much more convenient or now here you
could just do like alternate parking and
punch someone if they take your spot you
know I'm not doing that okay so let's
say I get a car and a garage and every
day I pick you up and we drive to the
shows together can it be a business
expense yes yeah yeah okay okay and you
know what I was thinking about New
Year's resolutions have you thought
about yours yet well no because I never
do them so I just thought it would be
and last year we got kind of [ __ ] on
our resolutions cuz like we made all
these plans and the best and they plans
yeah man plan got long God laughed at
all of our resolutions last year so I'm
reopen some of them are gonna be the
same as 2019 still needs to be the year
free stuff yeah because 2018 was a year
free stuff but not at the level I was
hoping for right it was like annoying
stuff
yeah like [ __ ] just showing up at my
house that I didn't order right or ask
for nor one yeah hopefully 2019 will be
the year of productive free stuff and I
will I had to postpone my plans to learn
how to cook but that I will do that this
year and also learning how to drive now
that we're joining the Country Club I
think it's pertinent
as I take one step out of the city and
one foot into the suburbs it's time for
me to learn how to drive okay that's my
resolution okay so but we'll do a whole
we're at solutions episode I just wanted
to get you thinking about it you know
yes a new perfume no I just got a whiff
of some fancy like old lady no that's
just talking to you okay well it is
Jackie and I said oh you know it might
be my hairspray Oh
it smells good thanks it is Jackie and
i's esteemed pleasure to deliver the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and taken by that of
your morning toast also there's some
live breaking news is there some live
breaking news so we're going to start
with it because on today's fourth hour
of The Today Show Kathie Lee Gifford
announced that she is leaving today
after 11 years thus opening the up the
fourth hour of The Today Show to a more
millennial focused hour
Kathie Lee Gifford has announced that
she's leaving The Today Show after 11
years the host may be an emotional
announcement on Tuesday alongside her
longtime partner and co-host Hoda Kotb
quote never worked with a more beautiful
group of people Gifford said on the show
Tuesday while copy told her co-host the
minute you step into my life it changed
Hoda went on to say quote you chose me
and that's how it started I was thinking
about how everything good that's
happened in my life has happened since
you came that's really cute prior to
joining today Gifford had a longtime run
alongside reaches filming on Live with
Regis and Kathie Lee wow I remember when
that changed to live with Regis and
Kelly and I remember thinking how are
they gonna get people to stop saying
Live with Regis and Kathie Lee but now
it sounds so weird yeah also um don't
get me wrong an end of a beautiful era
but maybe time for an update facelift
over at today's Today Show and I dunno -
morning show hosts who love to drink
wine in the morning who might be
available for this gig and for the 10
o'clock slot like that's really perfect
for us so but here's the obvious
question and you and I spoke about this
at length and you table let's see I'm
gonna ask us this question
hypothetically they reach out and we
only need one of you and let's say they
did that to you or they did that to me
do you take it I forget what week the
agreement that we came to
um but yeah yeah Doug with the show
could go on I'm like if you well if I
took it the show really couldn't go on
because I'm never here but if you if I
took it you could go on and you would
find look if you had to find a permanent
co-host who would you want to be oh
there's some good there's some really
good choices yeah one of the usual
suspects who helps us like often like
Heather's moving back to see there's
Daren there's Taylor so I or snitch like
smooth there's a lot that could be done
I mean the show would definitely be
changed or like say you took it well
then you do DJ tea so it's it's hard so
say I took it weakened technically they
do the toast are two o'clock right but
let's say contract
they were like this is the only work you
can do oh well sayonara has to check out
big it's gonna show money okay sayonara
sayonara yeah but then what would you do
just be a full time comment maybe
honestly maybe that's not the worst idea
anyway
totally but I want to be on this a show
that's sure but then like you're just
you're not as he show you have a
permanent platform that's true I'll
never let them come for you maybe that's
idea right it like really might actually
work out if anyone's having so much more
money I just wonder what the audition
probably right right they'd love to
promote from within I'm The Today Show
so I really don't foresee this being an
actual issue for us shockingly
it's gonna be you know Natalie Morales
or one of those other girls like that
are like I just want to get a read for
it you know yeah no no I'm gonna
literally cut my hair again just for the
audition like to the morning show host
Bob and just wear like the cutest little
Chanel suit okay do be your audition
okay but I need a teleprompter that's
the key is the teller Jota has a nice
ring to it especially Jackie Oh Jackie
Hoda Jackie no problems
hold up she would want to go first so
Hoda and Jackie looks fatty Lee odden
Kathie Lee or Kathie Lee and Hoda Kathie
Lee and Hoda but Jackie oh and Hoda
would then go to the top
yeah but the syllables make the most
sense okay but like I haven't only
respected reporter Hoda and Jackie O
really cute Jackie Onoda Hoda and Jackie
O show so just read the news of Kathie
Lee okay
in Today Show voice yeah with like your
with your natural commentary but also
with you leaning on the teleprompter as
everyone on television does okay Gracie
is on the teleprompter they put the
story and your commentary you know what
I mean
are you really never gotten you can like
just show up and not have a thought in
your head and just read which is so
crazy
yeah I might need to get a contacts if I
ever got hired by the Today Show cuz I
can't see anything
yeah nobody did that look at the TPG
Awards it was a teleprompter and I had
to bring up no cards on stage because I
couldn't see it grandma okay ready and
action take 1 scene 1 Jackie O audition
for Kathie Lee Gifford in this morning's
news that really has brought a tear to
the morning show host community we bid
farewell to Kathie Lee Gifford she's
leading the fourth hour of The Today
Show after 11 years of hard work Wow
beautiful and you didn't even look down
I'm eight and I didn't even have a
script so I would do it yo this [ __ ] at
out work with she's done you want to
hire me stuck on that one oh my god me
girls
oh sure so suck on that um well Barry
you know I feel like Kathie Lee is
really like she's done you know Hoda
still has that fire in her like she got
the new she filled in for Matt Lauer
like she still has the entrepreneurial
he's just getting started
I think Kathie Lee like was really taken
down hard by the death of her husband
and like she's just ready to retire now
her heart isn't in it and I love that
there was never really a competitive
vibe between Kathie Lee and Hoda when
you think that there would be you just
assumed that there would because we're
just competitive human being and I love
to pit women against each it's just like
us yeah of course
do you feel better you know sometimes I
do
Misha shows up with her hair done and
her makeup did and I'm like over here
with my strep throat but you have a good
singing voice so like you always had
just her all back do you feel
competitive with the singing thing no I
really don't because like the things
that you're gonna end the things that
I'm like good really you know we don't
really cross over even do you think we
do all the same things we do all the
same things but like interests wise but
couldn't be more different
great we're talented in very different
ways like you're a true comic and I'm a
true host that's the thing about being
multi-talented like we are it's amazing
think about yeah okay next story is so
crazy because Nicki Minaj is dating a
sex offender and now she's defending him
had you not seen that I'm so not here
for a kimono I I try and live my life
with horse blinders on so that I never
have to come in contact with Nicki Minaj
I really [ __ ] don't like her and I
actually had an article you know that
Demi Lovato said that she went to the
Met Gala and left him went to an AE
meaning because celebrities were so mean
to her she alluded and I read this
article proving that it was Nicki Minaj
because they were both there with Jeremy
Scott and that was interesting yeah I
agree but Nicki Minaj is Instagram
official with a registered sex offender
according to the blast her boyfriend is
a registered sex offender who was
convicted for the attempted rape of a 16
year old girl in the photo posted by
Minaj she has her legs wrapped around
her bow with the caption quote did you
ever make it out of that town where
nothing ever happens it's no secret that
both of us are running out of
according to and must be one of hers no
I don't know
total according to the end well I know
this information so now you need to be
shook okay according to the NYPD sex
offender unit database SVU
for short petty was convicted in 1995
for attempted rape in the first degree
for an incident that occurred in 1994
the same year that Claudia Asha was born
sure her the database cops noted that
the offense was quote sexual intercourse
and that a knife slash cutting
instrument was used as a weapon during
the crime he was sentenced to 18 to 54
months in prison but is unclear how much
of that time he actually served
where did she meet him apparently it's a
rekindled old flame and then she went on
Instagram last night and defended him
she said he was 15 she was 16 in a
relationship but go off Internet y'all
can't ruin my life y'all can't even run
y'all can't run my life y'all can't even
run your own life
okay well the song is hello did you ever
make it out of that town where nothing
ever has quoted a secret honestly
respect that the both of us her running
out of time hello from me honestly this
isn't the first time no that was like I
really belted it they know from like
10:30 11:30 to put in there the other
air pods
um or they're watching here's the thing
they're definitely not here's the thing
the thing is the thing is about Nicki
Minaj is I'm sorry like okay here's what
we can compare it to cuz here's what's
also going out in the news Kevin Hart
saying something six years ago has he
changed does he still feel that way it's
not really the same as raping someone at
knifepoint a couple of years ago you
know what I mean it's like people can
change but can they change that much I'm
not sure right I know so there's a
difference between making a joke that
offends but doesn't physically hurt
anyone
versus visiting yes well here's what
she's saying that they were dating but
just be and he was actually younger than
her so you could still be raped by your
boyfriend no
it was like a statutory thing because of
their age but then she's not addressing
the knife of it of it all yeah well it
would have said statutory rape but I
know it's not statutory rape because he
was under 18 - it's only statutory of
one of the men put I mean persons you
know I'm actually very unfamiliar with
Delores with statutory rape law like I
don't and I think everything is kind of
different yes I believe that overall the
law is that if it's a person is over 18
and another person is under 18 it's
desperate but if they're kids in high
school have sex all the time as long as
they're both under 18 right but like
what if someone a senior is 18 and their
girlfriend is a junior and they're 17
yeah I don't know technically maybe it's
just like you shouldn't be having sex at
that age I don't know that's like the
law trying to tell you when you should
have like a big period when it comes
like kids having sex oh my god I maybe
it's just cause like I'm a big weenie
and I waited a long time and they've
only had sex with one person but like I
don't know what kids these days are
[ __ ] wild losing their virginity at
14 and like smoking pot and doing jewels
in high school like I'm not down with
that my kids will not be doing that
I mean you can only hope you know but
like I'm like relatively cool I think
look I understand that like kids drink
and they're gonna be out late and I
don't plan on being like a crazy nuts
parent but like when it comes to sex
like there's so many possibilities and a
lot of negative ones like STDs and
there's so little education I can't let
my little TWRP of a daughter or son like
be out there contracting viruses right
but then other the flipside and I agree
with you but just playing devil's
advocate for a second is that if you
taste courage time from having sex
totally meaning that you won't even like
talk to them or educate them about it
and say they do go out and have sex but
they don't know anything like especially
like yes their sex ed in schools but no
one's paying attention right like if
they hear it at home like really the
danger is in blah blah blah but then it
also seems like you're encouraging them
exactly it's tough it's tough
someone said something interesting
statutory is consensual but they aren't
at the age of consent okay so I guess
statutory rape is like they shouldn't
use the rape word because I don't know
but this there's nothing statutory about
this it just says right it's just rape
and there's a because they were both
under 18 and there's a weapon ya know a
homegirl you can try and divert you can
try and make this a divine diversion
Nicki Minaj but it is anything but that
it's anything shady but she she need to
like she worked with Takashi's 69 guy
who like also as a convicted child
brother
I just feel like I don't know maybe she
like is has a low tolerance for things
like that you know when it comes to
finding a man she has a hide right yeah
the bar is is low I mean I think that
just speaks to society tonight it's hard
to it's hard to catch a man I start to
catch a man who doesn't like little kids
what the [ __ ] is going on that part's
not hard but even if you're Nicki Minaj
I just I couldn't disagree with that
less like I know a million those guys
with 401ks who would want to date Nicki
Minaj and I've never raped anyone I
don't know maybe you should set them up
okay I know what a lot of yeah I think
she just needs to know like you can do
better girl like yeah don't settle don't
settle for a sex offender okay next
story and we're just gonna keep updating
you because I really do feel like this
is really taking the nation by storm
it's really dominating the dialogue and
who the [ __ ] gonna host the Oscars
yeah oh my god I don't know the Academy
looks warily at Oscar host options as
board meeting looms Kevin Hart's abrupt
departure as Oscars host has left the
Academy of Motion Pictures Arts and
Sciences scrambling to find someone to
take the gig as of now the situation
remains fluid as the group's leadership
explores options including going host
lists individuals familiar with the
situation told variety the Academy was
blindsided by hearts announced departure
Thursday night according to two insiders
the Board of Governors will convene on
Tuesday night at a previously scheduled
meeting where the matter will inevitably
be discussed quote they're freaking out
set a top comedy agent speaking on the
condition of anonymity is that your
agent yes there were no contingency
plans in place by the academy or
broadcaster ABC according to another
Insider the show's producers are back to
square one late night host might seem
like the obvious choice given their
national profiles and histories with the
show think Kimmel Jon Stewart David
Letterman but the Academy is now said to
be gun-shy about going with someone
anyone who might be too edgy no Dan in
black resource then again going to safe
could be fatal for the show's record low
ratings the telecast was watched by
twenty five point six million people in
March a 19 percent drop from the
previous year
honestly twenty five point six million
people like its hood you really didn't
have anything better to do someone just
needs to like not worry about competing
with the Oscars and put a great show on
that night the same time Sun and they'll
get the eyeballs I can't lie like I'm
truly just like grateful and excited
about the downfall the inevitable
downfall of the Academy Awards
because I can't get over that your
hypocrisy of just of them as an
institution and then always just like
being in [ __ ] annoying and like
entitled and hypocritical but I'm really
just tired you know who's gonna do it
yeah and I get what they're saying like
if they do like a straight up like
savage comic they're gonna take every
opportunity to mention the Kevin Hart
thing and I'm sure they don't want it to
be about that so if they go with someone
boring that is just a boring show right
I had a great suggestion the other night
no honestly I always loved to try to
suggest us but like that makes no sense
and like yeah right totally
aquafina Oh Jackie made a great call and
honestly I think she might get it like I
don't know if they've been looking at
her and I don't even think they're even
thinking - but here's what what has to
happen obviously it has I think it's
better if it's a woman of course um it's
always better if it's a woman and not a
white woman thanks to Nick Cannon he's
made sure that your white woman will not
be off all the demographics and it kind
of no white women so we like were no men
period regardless of race no white women
so now it has to be a diverse woman and
someone who's young and hip and not too
edgy and someone who like really needs
the gig that they wouldn't go like this
would be like the biggest opportunity
for Aquafina she wouldn't go rogue and
make like a bunch of jokes about Kevin
Hart unless it was approved she would
say like they could tell her behave she
would behave um she's really coming up
and I think she would also do a great
job she did a great job on SNL and it's
also like the year of Aquafina and I
think that they should give her a chance
it definitely would be a leap for her
career-wise and they would definitely be
taking a chance on an unknown relatively
youtuber but I think that that might be
the direction they need - especially if
they want to engage a younger audience
Jackie I think that's one of your best
ideas I really thought long and hard
about it all right well let's make it
happen or they could you one of the
women from SNL but again who couldn't be
white narrows it down yeah Leslie I love
Leslie Jo
I love her she's [ __ ] funny it
actually be great there's a lot of good
options literally any one man woman who
cares like there are good options and we
just got our heads together oh you could
always fall back on Tiffany Haddish oh
that is a great coffee we talked about
her doing it earlier but then I guess we
just decide maybe she's too green she's
very friendly with Kevin Hart
yeah
yes oh maybe she wouldn't do it but yeah
I'm gonna say Tiffany Haddish
or Leslie or Aquafina interesting and
Tiffany Haddish just recently hosted the
VMAs which is a lot less prestigious but
she has experience she is a hosting
experience and you know if she needed
any tricks of the trade like we'd be
happy to meet with her give me a call
I've got a phone next story a little bit
more of economical news because I really
found it to be so interesting but gas
prices have plummeted - okay this
headline from USA Today is very confused
gas plummets to 2018 low as oil slide
delivers savings okay [ __ ] that headline
gas prices are the lowest they've been
in years you guys such a great time for
us to get a car to head to the Country
Club
totally gas prices hit a low for the
year on Monday as oils plunge led to
relief at the pump for American
motorists the average national price of
gas like this is what's the problem with
like business stories it's like why is
they written like that we're American
motorists you know drivers it's called
people with cars get your gas now yeah
it's the lowest it's ever been can you
get like extra gas like like yes but not
that much you can get like up somewhere
nicer than you're in your garage or a
rainy day but you can only really get it
like a walk yeah like a gallon like a
jug I got two right here the average
national price of gas with two dollars
and 42 cents on Monday according to AAA
that was four since lower than a week
ago 28 cents lower than a month ago and
four cents lower than a year ago gap
since gas briefly topped $2 ninety cents
per gallon in October prices have
plunged fueling the slump oil slide amid
concerns about the economy and a glut of
petroleum production okay this is the
part that I don't even understand but
what's so crazy is we remember like when
we were kids and there was like that
whole gas crisis it was in July of 2008
gas prices went up to four dollars and
ten cents per gallon and now we're at $2
I just remember like being a kid and
like when Bush was president people were
always talking about gas prices and like
as someone who like didn't know how to
drive yet and like couldn't be bothered
with anything going on that didn't
involved her I was just so confused by
everyone's like obsessed with farting
and now a girl is like nobody talks
about gas anymore like the prices
because they've gone down so like you
know
you only hear from people when they're
angry I'm gonna kind of do you thievin
tell run about my announce we know no
news is good news that's true so I guess
it's been consistent but that's I just
want to let you guys know like if you're
low on gas today is the day madding
nestled up guests up in Missouri for a
dollar ninety-nine a gallon holla
good for you Wow boo and what's so crazy
it like you when you fill up your car I
guess some gas guzzlers take about 50
gallons but it depends what kind of card
if you have an energy efficient car
right and might take about 20 but those
bucks really add up when you're
multiplying by 20 I mean Ben has been
driving like Ben's mom drove him to
school in the city like no one really
tries but Ben's mom drove him to school
picked him up from school Ben they have
a car in the city like Ben drives always
so he's very much like a driver and he's
like obsessed with gas and he's like
always getting it you know and like I
remember the first time was like $70 and
I was like what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do it
like once a week depending on how much
you drive well as you wanted to say be
your announcement oh you know I never
really got to promote shamelessly
self-promoting mine outs when I made
yesterday I launched the first leg of my
2019 journey jeans tour it's one of two
announcements so if your city wasn't
there yet people are like I think I have
something against the West Coast or
against Al's know it's just like harder
to get it booked but it's in my plans I
would never not go somewhere where I
knew everyone was coming like on my list
of things to do is Toronto is Dallas is
the west coast like San Diego's Portland
it's an international tour well yeah
thanks to Toronto I can now call it the
world tour the best thing ever
yeah maybe I'll even make a stop in
Montreal like just so I can really make
it Mexico done Alaska the Bahamas while
you're there done so we'll just be a
couple people sitting around the pool so
how about those Nets a gas price well
and large return and I'm doing Foxwoods
but just like I mean what's really
exciting about the second leg is like
it's mostly theaters and a couple comedy
clubs and places I was like unsure of
like the toaster community so I'm doing
Foxwoods which is like the biggest venue
I've ever done and it's like Fox was
like everywhere does that like Jerry
Seinfeld does it know and like Rascal
Flatts right so honestly like if you're
in the area and you can't decide like
which one to go to like please go to Fox
Fox I think it's gonna be an all stets
teens on deck situation cuz I've never
actually been to Fox with and I the
white elite aren't you and I put it in
my thing I said I want the nicest room
and give me at a helicopter because it's
a little far I think I'll see the TBG
could do okay and TBG wants to come
because I don't know if you know this
like he's also a degenerate gambler and
he was
he's like he can't raise a boy he
humbles a sport he's [ __ ] crazy she
was like I think I'm gonna come to box
but so I'm really gonna make it like a
steamy affair cuz I really just want to
sell out box so it's like I think that
would be like the coolest thing ever
and now I'm just like and then you'll be
there and we'll all go out like you can
find us you know afterwards so if you're
looking for a toasty night out Foxwoods
is the night and it's like now I'm
playing at venues like I've actually
been to four concerts so in Huntington
New York I'm playing at the Paramount
Theater which iswhat Kacey Musgraves
they're like that's [ __ ] cool and
I've never been to the Fillmore in Sandy
I mean in spring sultry spring what the
[ __ ] is it called Sandy Springs that's
what I did in Atlanta now I keep getting
confused you look at your thing
spring springs what the [ __ ] in Maryland
it's called um Spring Valley spring no
it's pretty spray spray Steen it's the
second word of spring Spring Break is
sandy springs sunny no say if someone
will get it sultry filter thank you so
much rings and that's a Fillmore which
like they it's like a franchise like I'm
just like really excited to be playing
in places like now people have heard of
you know and then the second drop I'm
making a plan for Dallas making plan for
Chicago New York Toronto all the places
but this first drop was really exciting
and the tickets were like doing really
well the last time I got a count but I
get the full count in 24 hours so like
I'm just like really nervous instead it
tickets are available at Carl's no job
calm and as if things couldn't go any
more wrong like I love the toasters and
they found all the links to the shows
before I even got to announce it like
ticket started going before pre-cell
even started because they're so crazy
and great but then once I finally
announced it my [ __ ] website went
down because it was just crashed my
website so then I was like on the phone
I was being so it was just really like a
very a very special moment like but
really all good problems to have oh my
god totally people are like are you
upset that the tickets leaves I'm like
[ __ ] though - we're coming oh you got my
tickets so sad so yes we're hitting
Huntington were holding baltimore Silver
Springs Maryland we're in Orlando we're
hitting Tampa we're hitting Connecticut
for the Foxwoods we're hit in Greensboro
North Carolina up Greenville South
Carolina
tickets available girls no drop calm I
love that I'm just excited and the great
news is even if the shows a little far
from you gas prices are in
I'm low so fill up Roadtrip get some
fellow toasters hit the road also I have
a really good road trip playlist if you
guys need I planned the tour really
smart because I told them I want to do
shows two weeks out of the month and one
of those weeks needs to be on the
weekend so I don't miss the toast okay
so hopefully I'll only be missing like
three toasts a month okay we'll figure
it out yeah like what happened this fall
was like what you were gone so much yeah
and it was fine and it really was it
really was even though there's like such
a dearth of talent in New York I can't
even begin no it's a Jew road if I've
ever seen one but I've heard that Kathie
Lee is now available so maybe I can
connect Kathie Lee like what the Today
Show to launch a podcast under the
morning toast that'd be [ __ ]
hilarious that would be okay are you
ready for a fifth and final story
speaking of hilarity a fire festival
rages on with a new nemesis every sorry
if some of the the tickets still have
presale codes and it's all capitals
genes je ans genes all caps okay fire
festival rages on with a new Netflix
documentary because there's no way to
put out the flames started by fire
festival we're now getting a second dock
on the catastrophe Netflix has announced
fire and elegy for the quote greatest
party that never happened directed by
Chris Smith and produced by by studios
it'll take you inside the knock so not
so Lux festival created by the all-time
scam artist Billy McFarland and ja Rule
that duped Instagram influencers and
concert goers alike into attending a
destination music festival advertised as
paradise that turned out to be hell on
earth MacFarlane was recently sentenced
to six years in prison and branded a
quote serial fraud surfer the whole
scheme the doc promises a first-hand
look into the disastrous crash of fire
as told by the organizers themselves
meanwhile Hulu also has its own
competing docu-series on the debacle
coming this year
Netflix is dock premieres January 18th
pathetic excuses for sandwiches and all
January 18th I know where I'll be no
totally love Netflix is always in tune
like they bought the rights to that
Adele B story like they're really on it
but it's so crazy when like it's clear
that people in Hollywood aren't
communicating because to of the exact
same movies are made at the same time
like this one of them is a show and one
of them is documentary it said that Hulu
was a docu-series okay but uh yes but at
the end of the day like really this all
happened within 24 hours it's not like
the people were intending to read
documentaries where
he's like social media footage and
interviews and it's like there's not
enough there there for two da ki
also let's be real the Netflix when it's
gonna be better yeah uh uh yeah we don't
even talk you series on the system
asleep i Julia 48-hour crisis right I
love that it happened no I mean
obviously not that I love that I love
that happened in this time period though
because there's so much footage us on
like people's instagrams people who are
like vlogging cuz they brought so many
influencers so we're gonna have like
some premium content I really hope to
see like Bella Hadid you know yeah but
she was never that's also like the part
of the scam that people leave out is
like Bella and Emily Ratajkowski like
promoted they were in the promotional
video as if they were going to this
thing now that they were in on the scam
but like they didn't look into it either
right I just took that check and ran and
they didn't even go and they said they
were going to write Kendall - yeah and
they just get out scot-free which I mean
it's not their fault but it's like
everything factories let like made it
the [ __ ] show that it was and made
people go if you're just this random guy
Billy MacFarlane was putting on festival
not everyone would have shown up also I
just think it's like this is a true
testament like how dumb some people are
like people who can just get so like
transfixed by what happens online and
being like oh well Bella's going like
I'm gonna be cool and go to and spend
like thousands of dollars I didn't think
for one [ __ ] second about going and I
feel really good about that I have to be
honest win the video through and the
promo video came out like Zach sent it
to me like as if it looked cool and I
was like [ __ ] no and I just like that
I think I I don't know I think that I'm
like easily manipulated by the media but
look I'm not I didn't go yeah yeah and
they dropped coin but there did you see
that Dwayne the rock Johnson was
watching three identical strangers um
yes because he's definitely toasting
with a plate of cookies um I love him so
much like truly and I love that he was
watching 302 in total strangers and
shedding light on the importance of the
documentary and the importance of just
like knowing your family background
which is why I did 23andme yeah I wonder
if he's done 23andme if he said
descendant of a real rock now that you
did it and you yeah he's the descendant
of a gem stone from the Stone Age right
ooh his roots go back to the seasons you
send in a Fred Flintstone
by the way now that you got yours in
your 100% Jewish like do you see other
Jewish people and like you take a moral
high ground about them because you're
more Jewish than them um yes
no I definitely made me like think
differently about like my life
and I and I absolutely I know I've said
this for I must get Zach I ordered him a
cake using our code manages which is 23
in me calm hush toast which I would let
you know again but I just need to make
sure he's like semi on my level of pure
teh right okay what is the lowest Zach
could be without like you raising an
eyebrow anything under 50 we just be
completely oh no no because there are
like legit Jews who are like 75 like I
would have I would really be pleased
with 75 or above our during the people
of for ashkenaz people who spent a lot
of family perished in the Holocaust like
you don't know like your family so you
can only trace back especially like
people of Eastern European Jewish
descent can only trace back their
history so much and given like the lack
of information and the lack of it like
actual like death certificates during
the Holocaust
totally so fifty to seventy-five percent
I'll be um disappointed but yeah I will
forgive and zero to 50 like we're gonna
have to talk okay and you guys can get
23 me uh test as well here's how now
through December 25th get 30% off of any
23andme kit order your DNA kit at
23andme calm slash toast that's the
number two three a nd me calm slash
toast
again that's 23andme calm slash toast
honestly it's an amazing gift for anyone
because literally everyone needs to do
it you're adrift of information anything
we're priceless than that information
about yourself and maybe you might
actually be giving them the gift of like
more family if it comes if they come to
find out that they have like other
relative mentions yeah okay so can you
google about the symptoms of the strep
arcus like I really think I have it my
back hurts so much and I can't swallow
did you see one of the toasters they
were list I guess they're a doctor like
they're someone they live with as a
doctor and they were listening to the
Heather McMann episode and they were
like that girl has pneumonia you know
she said but she said that someone has
told her that before and she got cleared
though she'll say oh she did okay cool
okay symptoms people may experience pain
circumstances can occur while swallowing
whole body fever chills or malaise what
smell is tiredness but that's it that's
everybody how are you Liz wait can you
feel like alright dad gastrointestinal
nausea
no not yet but I'm also common sore
throat enlarged neck lymph nodes uh
swollen tonsils tender lymph nodes
tonsillar exudate bad breath oh god yeah
stress well I do have 200 a let me feel
your let me feel your head in your
glands okay I feel like I tell me what's
just a bright light tell me what do you
think of sore wow you don't even have
glands and I'm gonna lie like they're
not swollen
you're not even touching it yes I am
they're not even feel yours I achieved
really big glands do you feel that no it
just feels like neck no no whatever I'm
self diagnosing anyway I need some
amoxicillin I'm really not bill to fix
it the Malay is taking over the general
malaise done five stories yeah
oh okay let's talk my venom from brawls
that's and you catch up on OC no cuz
they weirdly put it on Sunday night they
slipped it in there like they just got
real last episode okay well I'm still
catching up I'm great and you're
catching up on the whole show yeah okay
but Vanderpump rules let's jump right in
also next week
Danna from pearls is not on Sunday did
you see that they're sneaky - yeah - and
it looks so good but they also put a
commercial for next week's episode in
the middle of this week they said there
before it's weird they but it looks good
yeah Katie goes to lease and is like
meet him yeah and even though that she
katie is gonna get chosen over of course
as well she should
James shouldn't be working there like
also not only this is like willing
everyone found me mean to everyone but
like the way that he acted like in the
parking lot just like like he was so
[ __ ] up at pride right when I was
working yeah you're why is Raquel like I
know that she wants to be on a show and
like this is the only way she could have
gotten on it but like she's really I
think I just liked her more than I just
like James I don't know I really like do
you feel badly for her but because like
I'm sure all the other girls felt badly
for her for a long period of time but
now it's like she's complicit because
she's right really should know but at
this really pretty yesterday she did
look really pretty and I also thought
that like if you just want to assume for
a second that they're in a good
relationship and like she loves him and
blah blah blah I'm like the way that
Kristen and hope approach from the
bathroom I thought the way that she
handled it was actually really well and
like I mean Kristen like doesn't have
the right intention and when she said
look we're here
I'll feel like we care about you like no
one in their right mind would believe it
and honestly if I was Raquel I'd also be
like Kristine like [ __ ] off like oh so
like I'm so here for Kristen taking
James down and what was so funny is when
she was talking to Stassi about it like
being insane she was wearing a shirt
that said James
yeah because her company's called James
nay that's so crazy it's weird it's
really weird she's like obsessed or so
it seems
yeah and like if you're gonna take James
down bringing in some random girl to say
that she stopped with him like isn't the
way didn't she learn that with Miami he
got to it the formula for the show is
like if you want to take someone down
and bring in that someone they hooked up
with know like she really should have
been like getting what what wound up
happening should have been her plan
which is that he causes a scene on
certain loses his job right she can push
him there like she can get him yes I
totally kind of you know it was like
really wonky and I think that this
season might be like Kristin's downfall
just from what I see in the trailers
like it looks like she's a mess that was
so trashy
that's a funny sign that dude that was
so trashy I [ __ ] love Lala
I [ __ ] love Lala she was so great in
last night's episode she know who look
really over hmm
Ariana well I was never under but close
Tom sand of all he's really starting to
piss me off and like he keeps just
talking about Jackson Brittany in a
negative way I think because he's like
jealous oh yeah she wants to get married
and Ariana doesn't want to get married
and I don't like it I hate when people
like cake people's happiness whatever
whatever you have to say about it and
like make it about them like make it
nasty I hate that that's like saying
mean things about someone on their
wedding day I don't think there's
anything more evil innately that's why
when a girl texted me like a week after
my wedding saying I stole her ideas like
first of all no I didn't second of all
[ __ ] you
you know yes and yes I agree with you
and yeah it's like I feel like even as a
viewer I can see that Jax changed in one
episode his whole approach he's like
philosophy about life and Brittany and
like and his dad like it's just on point
it's like he got it overnight and so it
takes something major like that's change
a person and just like you've been
friends with him for this song if you're
gonna stay his friend this whole entire
time even while he was a shitty person
at least give him the benefit of a doubt
of the doubt when he's being a good
person yep and I really think the only
person who understands had a Stassi and
I love how she was like being so helpful
with the party when she was like Lisa
called the ceilings cottage-cheese
ceiling and his sofa
that is so funny and it's like why do
James and Raquel have the nicest
apartment when I know that the rest of
them make more money than he does I
think like hell might come from like a
nice money family I just feel like it's
in their contract that they're not
allowed to move into an apartment that's
more than two thousand dollars because
it would be confusing cuz like Jax
saying that after he bought the ring he
needed money and wants to work at Sur
again like please you can I mean they're
making like fifty grand an episode yeah
but if he works at Sur he'll get paid
more on my show Lisa is such a [ __ ]
like [ __ ] she can't just be nice and
she was like yo mother since Jax you
should check if it's cubic zirconia [ __ ]
you you know what like that's so rude
and I'm really like so over Lisa
Vanderpump they should change the show
to pump rules I like every time they go
back to sur I'm like this is stupid go
home well you don't even work here I
totally agree and she's such a [ __ ] I
can't eat but also now in real life
Jackson Britney are making wedding plans
are getting married at a Kentucky castle
I love them like seeing them on watch
what happens live like she is they're so
happy I love them so much there was
something else I wanted to talk about I
don't even remember maybe about James
and his apartment and his countertops
yeah when it comes in this countertop oh
I wanted to see them no Kristen which is
that also I think Kristen like is really
obsessed with J was because if it wasn't
for Kristen yes she gonna be the Mon
thankful against Tom Sandoval James
wouldn't even be on the show Kristen
feels responsible for the monster that
is James Kennedy as she should and now
she thinks it's her job to get him off
the show that they all they all are so
personal about the show cuz they've
really put their whole lives out there
in the show is a success because each
and every one of them had never like
hidden anything which is why they were
so mad at Stassi when she went I'm a
Patrick on the show it's like you don't
get that privilege so now it's like they
take it all so personally like the fact
that James is a part of it and them are
really friends to them I think pisses
them off and the fact that Kristen is
one responsible for bringing him into
the mix like she'll never forgive
herself yeah and also like why are Tom
and Ariana friends with them I don't
know and like and where the [ __ ] is
scheana I don't know I feel like she
really like loses touch with them when
they're not filming and then it takes
her a few episodes to get back into the
mix maybe yeah it's it's weird her and
Jax were fighting on Twitter yesterday
she was so funny he they're both like
[ __ ] hilarious yeah no I like her on
the show like and also someone always
has to be the outside or else it doesn't
work ya know that's the formula for a
perfect Bravo show I need to put a
heating pad
like I'm really not sure oh and then
Stassi wasn't watch what happens live
and she looks L was in the audience and
they're so cute and so cute and weird
totally like you to sweat in the Ketan
like [ __ ] obsession was death yeah
they're just like too hot nerds that
found each other and much meaner to have
and she's writing a book she wrote a
book yes I saw I'm gonna read it
I love reading reality tea no I'm gonna
parse it and like leave it on my mantle
I just don't really like to read it's a
nice color for an apartment it's like a
baby blue no I really do love to read
like so let's not else so yeah just like
it gives me a really clear picture of
who they are so I mean thank you guys so
much for joining us on this fine Tuesday
morning Jackie and I are gonna I'm gonna
relax today because we have a big night
coming up so stay tuned on Instagram we
are so close we're at 98.1 yeah well
we'll get there soon oh my god that
picture of James has Abraham Lincoln
funny and he commented on it tag [ __ ]
he's gonna be deejaying the party
tonight so maybe we'll see him maybe
I'll tag him [ __ ]
I did tag him after he wrote that cuz it
was [ __ ] hilarious that's it so make
sure to keep up with the chose to
Instagram at the morning toast we're so
close to 100 K what should we promise
when we get to 100 K that usually gets
people there we'll have to think about
it something good no it's like more
people listen to the show then we follow
on Instagram it like that's annoying
yeah the instagrams like just like the
easy more digestible version of the show
why wouldn't you want to follow it also
tomorrow we have special guests joining
us whoaaah kings and they're both like
so cute and like so legit famous I'm
like really excited to talk to new I
love their music I'm excited and it has
to go well cuz like once if they like us
like that they're part of like a big
team like maybe everyone also want to
come with the chainsmokers yeah get the
team involved so yeah that'll be fun
we'll put up a postcard postcard social
card on answer time for you to leave
questions for the Lost Kings if they're
single etc etc we love you guys and
we'll see you tomorrow
you